we go on the ground we now are getting
reports that in fact
two police officers have been shot
tonight in louisville
and transported to university hospital
here the very latest on the ground
is matt finn matt we have
metro police apparently confirming that
another officer was shot tonight
yeah and sean we have a crew on the way
to that shooting scene right now and we
will bring
the latest from that scene i just want
to show you what's happening here really
in the heart of downtown louisville
police
or people tried setting this facility on
fire earlier tonight and police came
rushing out of there and
protesters threw objects at police they
declared this an unlawful assembly there
are
remnants of fires all around this area
in fact there's still a smaller fire
still burning in this area but right now
we are past
that curfew time so police are out here
uh
you know warning people that this is an
unlawful assembly
they told people over and over again to
clear this area and there's still some
people hanging out you know screaming
profanities at police trying to agitate
them but for now this is
a much calmer scene than just even a few
hours ago when there was hundreds and
hundreds of people
out here uh and police declared this an
unlawful assembly and they warned people
that they would be arrested and
just a short distance from here our
understanding is that two police
officers were
shot here tonight in louisville we don't
have any word on their condition but we
will bring that to you as soon as we get
it sean
matt what do we know about apparently
there's reports that earlier that
uh we had an eyewitness here see a truck
that had
things that they were distributing to
anarchists
which would indicate that they were
planning for trouble very early on in
the day and
that that for example they were they
were holding
i guess giving out to different people
that were there
i guess fellow anarchists uh you know
all sorts of
water bottles and signs and other things
distributed we don't know for sure
everything that was given out but
apparently this there was some planning
involved in tonight's
well what happened tonight uh in in a
lot of different ways what can you tell
us about it
well sean just a short while ago i saw
of
several people throwing objects at
police water bottles
at police you know we saw people
lighting fires
on our air just a short while ago
someone threw what appeared to be a
firework
into a lit fire causing that to explode
so there was obviously some type of
orchestration or planned gathering here
tonight
the police did come out in force though
and they warn people over and over again
here
that this is an unlawful assembly and
they warn people to go home
and so people the protesters did flee
this area they did kind of respond
to the police warnings now you can see
that the police are still out here the
bobcats are out here
police are out in full force keeping an
eye on the people
who are still you know lingering in this
area we know
from recent protests that unfortunately
in the late night hours
bad actors often take advantage of this
situation
so police are out here in full force
right now there is lot order there is
peace here but unfortunately
not far from here two police officers
apparently shot tonight
so there is even more tragedy in this
story sean all right matt we just got
video
in uh we've not been able to
independently confirm it but it seems
like others in the media
are lex 18 news
has now confirmed our reporting that two
officers
with the louisville metro police
department have been shot
let's just roll it apparently it's sound
of
of the events of one of the officers
being shot let's listen
they're blasting at the police
i will go back to the scene in a moment